Ferguson never achieved the level of
success that Barcelona did Barcelona in
09010 that kind of four-year run that
Guardiola had it's the greatest Club
site ever I don't think anyone would
ever say the treble-winning site even
though it's amazing for Man United fans
that wasn't the best site to ever come
out of Europe that wasn't that wasn't
the generational side that side won
three in a row and the champions league
and a lot of those players went on to
win another you were knocking at long
four five years later to Dwight York and
all that I'm wearing the philosophy of
Johan cruifer and getting messy to play
as a false line score in 91 goals and
Academy messy carried my man he hasn't
won a Champions League without me
thank you
hello mate how are you doing uh what are
you doing
take a seat thanks very much oh what's
happening yeah I'm good mate FA Cup
Final you ready I'm gas yes we've been
here before we won a few trophies in the
last few years so Rarity for you to be
in a final so usually yeah I mean I mean
we've been in one in February yeah yeah
and this one is huge and I know City are
going to be massive favorites but yeah
at Jose Mourinho said sometimes football
Heritage is important that is true yeah
yeah I think 100 yeah at Wembley for
sure not one Manchester United player
would get into the city starting 11.
three two one
how far off the table can I go with this
mate can I go a quarter off to say I
don't spare anything
but I'm going as far off humanly
possible as that okay you're a very good
team but I disagree well who gets in I
think markers are actually good page
quite easily Marx rashford will probably
see it he'd get in the stadium I'd give
him a ticket you've got to remember what
you've got to remember yeah is that
these players will be coached by Pepper
as well and they would have been coached
by pep for the last three or four years
this is a one-off system you've got to
put that into the scenario Jack grish
plays on the left for us I take him
to run him out of town not me
no that was that was uh pundits I had no
idea about Man City fans love Jack
grealish he's a far more intelligent
footballer than rashford he's far more
his level is consistent now a lot of
people have said the numbers haven't
been good rashford's numbers have been
incredible this season of course that's
before we get to Rafael around casimiral
Ram casemiro he's got more Champions
Leagues than your whole club yeah that's
great that's in the past guess what that
was a different Club that's not a man
united
as I mentioned him yeah no way could he
could fight for a spot in your team
for anything I can start for anything
left back Luke Shaw gets in YouTube uh
left back no not for me
he's not a left back if he's been
playing left back make sure foreign
it's not the first substitution at 60
minutes it's the third substitution 88
minutes rashford's that guy for City at
the moment that's fair enough to him
he's fantastic he's a fantastic player
Jack reach is operating in it yeah
he is no he's not Mark's rashford's in a
team 20 goals in the four out of the
last five years I'm missing that because
Calvin Phillips hasn't worked out I
think Casimir has a rotation for
Rodriguez casimiro was that City you'd
already have a Champions League yeah
maybe maybe we are lacking that
leadership is it United playing in the
Europa League
he won't be next to you
Manchester City will never be as big a
club as Manchester United three two one
I think you have to say that let me go
first because otherwise yeah I'm not
going to sit here and say city or a
bigger Club than man united now I'm not
saying it would be a five-year process
even a 10 15 year it would take 20 30
years but the only thing I'm saying is
uh football is a long sport we're going
to be hopefully alive for you know
decades to come and a City win multiple
Champions Leagues it took Alex Ferguson
a long time to win his first trophy you
don't want to leave for decades up to
that had you so all I'm saying is
history is there to be written and The
Narrative of United being a massive Club
it will always be there of course but
things can change in the future so I'm
gonna say I think you've got a good
point especially like European cops and
things like that those things can change
quickly if City win the European Cup and
then win a couple more you start to look
at things but in terms of like that
those words again that football Heritage
and you've got to take into
consideration United's ownership
possibly going to change potentially
have new owners we will get Manchester
United challenging again so those
trophies should start rolling in again
yeah and even when we've been pretty
poor which we have been over the last 10
years we've still managed to contribute
you know a couple couple trophies here
in the League Cup finals so man united
will continue to do that but also you
look at the sheer number of all right
fans is one thing and I think that
matters but also like just look how many
people care about man united I don't
think people care enough about
Manchester City for them to be big
enough but that comes from winning a
treble in 1999 that comes from sporting
achievements and there's an argument
that you haven't had any you know major
sports achievements the last six seven
years you know you haven't won a league
in 10 years eventually that does a road
away and eventually history does you
know not on Forest one two European cups
you know decades ago that is almost
forgotten we're assuming though United
aren't going to win anything I'm
assuming that and that's not going to
happen I I don't think we're assuming
see you're going to continue to win
everything I can see it and once Pep
Guardiola does one
why not you could stay for 10 years
total Pep Guardiola would have to live
for 100 years
I strongly disagree about that Pep
Guardiola is a better manager than Sir
Alex Ferguson was
three I'm gonna be here all day
I'm gonna go here I'm gonna go here
I think I think he can get a team
playing football
better than Ferguson I think Ferguson
understood the psychology of management
there that's fair and then what you
achieved with the 99 season what you
achieved revolutionizing three or four
different United size 100 but I think if
you were folks have never achieved the
level of success that Barcelona did
Barcelona in 09010 that kind of
four-year run that Guardiola had it's
the greatest Club site ever I don't
think anyone would ever say the treble
win in sight even though it's amazing
for Man United fans and it's good for
the Premier League era that wasn't the
that wasn't the best site to ever come
out of Europe that wasn't that wasn't
the generational side it's one of them
of course it's a generation
you just said I don't think it is it's
not a generational side it is
and a lot of those players went on to
win another you were knocking at long
four four years later to Dwight York and
all that
the philosophy of Johann kreifer and
getting messy to play as a false line
score with 91 goals in the academy messy
carried my man he hasn't won a Champions
League without Messi yeah but yeah
and yeah we want to talk we can talk
about man united all day long and what
he achieved there fairly lead titles but
he's the last man to win anything in
Scotland that isn't a Celtic or Rangers
manager he's the last man to beat Real
Madrid in a European final he's done so
many different things before he even got
to Manchester United and I think you
have to give him credit for that dirty
League titles goals without saying yeah
he could have done more in Europe and I
think that's probably where pep will
will have the advantage on him yeah but
also Pep's gone into a Barcelona side
that was blessed with Messi and Javi
Iniesta and all that you're going to
Bayern Munich you know one one team
leader by Munich in a one team League he
hasn't had to you know do it yeah
Andy Cole 8 million back then is like
100 Mil now you know
how much money by the time Blackburn's
30 million on Ferdinand 30 million Van
Percy spent more than us he was spending
a lot of money Chelsea was spending more
than enough money Newcastle spending
more than us the big the big reality for
this for this question in particular
Alex Ferguson he lost half the
championship finals that he ever played
and both of them were against Guardiola
and he got he didn't just argue against
Messi well against Guardiola who got
Messi playing his best football ever
Messi's never been at the same level
since guadela left Barcelona
he hasn't has he ever been better since
but all I'm saying is you know Ferguson
lost two finals to Guardiola he
dominated the transit finals he played
his way Ferguson scraped on pens against
Chelsea in Moscow and he he fluked
against Bayern Munich let's be racist
there's a difference between food like
always
along the way to that Champions League
yeah decent decent ooh yeah
uh Bayern Munich and Barcelona were in
our group yeah yeah let's get that
finals
this team with ZIP down and all these
guys in there everyone says the Dan's
the greatest player ever guess what
Keenan scores that's also one of the
finals that Ferguson Juventus uh into
Milan but the finals that Ferguson
against Barcelona yeah but those two
teams and that one of those teams won
the Champions League the year before
yeah so you know they still had the
trophy in the bag
I mean you ask any man united for a
player we lasted finals badly from
Wembley especially the Wembley one but
I'd argue messy more than pep as we've
seen that City he ain't done it since
no way
Manchester United will be City's biggest
title Challengers next season
three two one
I don't
know plus it's possible on the line it's
possible goal line clearance I'm not
strongly agreeing until I see what
happens in the summer who our owners are
well there's a possibility at the moment
the glazes stay and that yeah exactly
because if that happens there's probably
no chance to be challenging for the
title probably ever again yeah if they
leave
depending on who the new owners are
you're looking at a different Beast you
also look at ten hog if he's given some
finances in the summer he's already
spent quite well it was last summer no
no it's not mean he's already spent
quite well you add some more you're not
dealing with the likes of their ghost up
front you know you've got a few more
midfielders in here definitely we've got
a possibility to challenge and if
Arsenal can challenge having finished
fifth fifth straight yeah
then you never know but you know to win
the league
ahead of City you can't have one team
challenging that's why you need three
teams yeah you need Liverpool to beat
City at one yeah Arsenal to beat City
because I've lost four games this season
right yeah and you're still going to win
the league
you need to be losing about five six
seven yeah you need those four plus two
defeats against your title challenges
yeah Arsenal couldn't do it if Arsenal
beat used that twice
or once you can do it different story
they couldn't do it so we need three
teams challenging and if United are one
of them we could do it I think United
needs seven or eight players to even get
close to the city you know seven or
eight I think it's less we do need the
right investment before we can challenge
yeah but you know what it is who if it's
not United
I don't see Arsenal challenging again
that's the thing yeah I see Liverpool
they have they made three or four away
from being where they were further away
from us you know not for me not for me
Manchester City will win the Champions
League before United win their next
Premier League title three two one don't
even know where to move this
it could happen in like a week it could
happen in a couple of weeks yeah
um I only lightly agree while you decide
just because I think there's a massive
Jinx over the club with the channel and
I do you look at Napoli in that other
side of the draw yeah they're in
unbelievable form they're both their
star players backfully fit and they
still can get past AC Milan with the
kind of the weight of the chambers
League The Heritage and being a city fan
as much as I think we've got the quality
for the last even for the last five
years consistently people have said
you're one of the favorites to win it
you should be winning it I can't
disagree with that with the money we've
spent of course but there's there's a
there's a weird hoodoo around the club
there's a weird weight that other clubs
even Chelsea had that expectancy of
getting to the challenging final playing
ugly and still winning it and City have
got a massive hurdle to overcome that it
feels like an England fan you know in
England you know England England score
goes to any World Cup where we feel that
we're favorites we bottle it a little
bit and that European trophy for city is
a hard thing to sort of become a news
European Championship it's difficult I
remember
when I was younger early 90s when we
started winning things again we got
knocked out to Monaco Dortmund right by
a Leverkusen in 2000s something when the
finals that happened like I know that
was after but just before Fergie went we
went out against teams that we shouldn't
have gone out to so I've you know you
kind of see that a lot it's because
because it's a cop competition anything
can happen in those games along the way
yeah so I'm disagreeing more out of Hope
than expectations yeah I I have to put I
have to back that eventually like
because eventually the money and the
quality of signings have been made it's
not just about money as we know with
Chelsea for example look within a couple
of years we won the Premier League you
know that the quality that we showed
against man united in the FA Cup
semi-final in 2011. yeah that was the
the weight of that quality got us over
the line and you have to say somewhere
along the line early Holland's going 50
goals it has to counter something yeah
do I mean it has to do something with
that you know it did for so many other
Strikers so hopefully it does for and
also realistically he's a lot more
closer to winning the Champions League
than we are at the moment at the moment
yeah but a good summer who knows
this Manchester City side
is the best side in premier league
history
three two one
oh okay yeah we're a lot closer
um
it could go down as it though yeah well
not it's one of
yeah it could potentially get near there
but at the moment until you have all the
marbles yeah you need the trophies uh I
think the Centurion season is is better
than this current season uh this current
side this season I think they've also
been better City teams in the fact that
in terms of the football that you play
yeah in terms of like you know when you
went up against that Liverpool team yeah
that was more impressive than going up
against this Arsenal team definitely
because everyone Arsenal gonna crumble
yeah that Arsenal played against City
lost every single time yeah against
Liverpool dead you know you lost some of
those games you won some of those games
it was a more even battle and maybe that
was more impressive
and this but then if this team gets all
three trophies or even maybe does a
double yeah the double because then he's
gone three in a row yeah three in a row
is important yeah do you know what I
mean yeah um so it could go down as one
of the greatest but
until you get that European Cup you
can't jump to 99 United and oh wait
United I I all I can say though when I
don't look at the cuts that we haven't
won in terms of the European Cup is is
just the way we play football I think if
you get 100 points in the Premier League
season the balance the pace David silver
fernandinho for me that was a lot more
well-rounded even companies in that side
a bit more leadership at the moment
obviously City could go on Twitter it
was like a couple months where
certificate in question when they were
trying to find their feet I know they
have found their feet now but it hasn't
been the free-flowing city throughout
the season although you can say they're
not always that way at the start you
know start slowly I can't think of a
single team in Premier league history
it's been completely I mean even the
Invincible side you know they didn't win
anything because there were about 20
games for a load of games so I can't
think of aside from beginning from
August to May United used to start
slowly as well it's hard it's hard
you've got to finish strong but if the
city Side finish with a treble they're
right up there with how we play then
they're in the top three teams I'll take
that then they're in the top three teams
with 99-08 where they are I don't know
but I agree with that one definitely
we'll discuss that at the end of the
season
winning the FA Cup
is no longer a major achievement for a
so-called Big Six Club
of its type in Europe the fa Cup's
incredible I love it I've loved it since
I was a kid I remember the 94 final 96
cop finals like those are some of my
earliest footballing memories the FA Cup
is still important yes one point on the
League Cup I think not everyone can win
the Champions League I think seeing you
know I know Watford got to the final few
years ago and lost 16-0 to us but you
know that's a real day out for it for a
football club I mean it's um it's major
both FA Cup semi-finals should not be
played at Wembley three two one
Old Trafford and Villa Park were used a
lot in my time I've gotten told uh Villa
Park for a few semi-finals over the
years you think of gigs against Arsenal
yeah yeah and we beat Watford there once
4-1 like there's just loads of Arsenal
one nil
um yeah just bring them back there makes
Wembley more special I think the big
thing is is fan you know the money that
fans spend on tickets especially City
we're talking about over 20 appearances
in the last 10 years at Wembley
serious money for people especially you
know I don't want to get political but
the kind of you know the cost of living
crisis that a lot of people are facing
you can't justify going to a semi-final
Wembley yeah and then expect if you win
prices
for semi-final without the dream of
going to the final so you end up having
to you know it becomes a double ticket a
double sort of cost of a ticket so it's
absolutely ridiculous that it ever got
put there and it was political and it
was financial and it was and I think
they're awful not only for those reasons
for the just make the cop better yeah
definitely Manchester United will win
the FA Cup this season three two one
laughs
I'm nervous you know I don't spill it
I'm just going to put it just wait
you've already done that
well on that side of the table
no I I think obviously a cup final
anyone you know we lost a Wigan so what
can I say but
we play our way we've already put six
pass through the FTL earlier this season
yeah congrats on that it was a big win
for you lot in your season but we're
talking about bigger things for us a
treble is on the horizon
as well I suppose because the players
are going to be especially if you're on
you know if there's one game after that
which could possibly make you treble
winners the United players will know
they can't allow that to happen yeah
maybe that will bring something out of
them it's going to be a weird game it's
going to be a different game there's
never been a Manchester Derby in a cup
final it's a one-off and again
don't have to beat him it could just go
extra time
it could be done so I don't know I've
got a good I got a good feeling you know
so Manchester City will win the treble
this season
three two one
I don't strongly disagree you know
because it could happen but there's
gonna come a load of pressure
on Manchester City doing the treble you
know it's going to start getting talked
about more more than when United were
possibly going to win it yeah because we
were still in a title race to the last
day of the season with Arsenal you know
we didn't even know if we're going to
win the league now the League's kind of
sewn up you're already in a cup final
yeah you're three you're two games away
from potentially doing it and the Talk's
gonna ramp up yeah the pressure's gonna
ramp up and we've seen in the past in
Norway we could have done it we lose
against Portsmouth in the FA Cup because
kushak gets sent off how old traffic
looks like just Anything Could Happen a
red card something that's why I strongly
disagree I think the weight of football
history is on is against us you were
amazing to do it in 1999 you can't give
me aside before in 100 Years of football
history in this country
yeah but but at that point bar said
never no one in Spain had ever done it
up to Guardiola he did it what in 2008
or that kind of or 2009 that kind of
period of time so there's a hundred
years of Spanish football history that
we'd never seen it in Spain before as
well so the weight is against us in
terms of how hard it is to do and that's
why I strongly disagree now if it was
purely based on football and ability I
I'd move the glass here because Harland
Ruben Diaz rodri we have a spine of a
side that could win a treble I'm sorry
we do we have a world-class football
site especially when you look at the
teams you're potentially going to come
up against you know but when a quarter
final is Bayern Munich Harlan misses a
penalty these are small moments we did
very well to beat Bayern Munich but in
the quarter final we're already seeing
Harland miss a penalty there's a couple
of niggly moments against arsenal we
also beat Arsenal but
those get magnified in a when you know
again you talk about the sending off of
kushak for example you know Edison's got
a mistake in him Carl Walker has got a
red card in for sure so that's why I
just I disagree because I think it's
just it's the odds are against you
aren't they good see you mate nice one
I've had a sip because I'm uh I've just
been bantering you too much yeah you
might need to but finals coming up um I
would wish you luck but yeah what's the
score prediction
Manchester United to win two on I
strongly disagree
all right we'll see you later
do you think your team that you played
with can be better than the team that I
played with yeah that can't happen
please England anyone you played with oh
yeah definitely won it no I don't think
I've got Shira I've got the lot yeah no
but I got Salah
how would you get in Philadelphia